c'est au musée historique de villèle que
les agents d arrondissement sud et ouest
du département sont venus assister aux
voeux du président et directeur général
des services soulignant l'engagement à
venir des élus et des agents pour cette
nouvelle année 2010 9
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les élus je suis fier monde
d'administration de vous présenter les
voeux des agents du département de vous
souhaiter plein succès dans l'exercice
de vos missions et ses missions sont
délicates des gilets jaunes ont été
extrêmement critique à l'égard des élus
et c'est souvent très injuste mais il
faut répondre à cette demande
je souhaite vraiment les initiatives que
vous prenez les actions vous vous
engagez soit mieux comprise par les
rideaux des je souhaite en conclusion
que l'année 2019 soit vraiment une année
féconde et prospère pour tous les
réunionnais et tous les agents du
département agents techniques et
administratifs
ils étaient plus de 500 à avoir fait le
déplacement
c'est un moment très important que
monsieur malcor mais ça en place ça veut
dire que nous considère vraiment comme
ces agents on travaille toute l'année on
souhaite que en fin d'année le président
ne présente ses voeux et nous donne ses
appréciations sur notre travail qu'on a
accompli toute l'année c'est un moment
où on peut retrouver les collègues d'une
part et d'autre part voir le président
en personne ça fait comme du bien de
devoir de percevoir de toucher presque
le président parce que c'est notre
patron mais on entend
on essaie de suivre ce qui fait
politiquement et sur le terrain et
fiat a un coût directement si en place
quoi commencer ça donne toujours avancer
dans l'activité important et toujours
pour être
au service de notre collectivité
important c'est le mot d'ordre de
président cyrille melchior valorise
l'action de ses agents dans leur mission
de service public 2018 a été une année
riche d'événements marquée par la
signature du pacte de solidarité
territoriale avec les 24 communes de
l'île
avec également des difficultés
climatiques et la mobilisation des gilet
jaune 2019 sera porté par un engagement
fort de toute la collectivité dans ses
missions au plus près des réunionnais au
zoo innover aux au dialogue et aux
structures et aux eaux disputées les
avec les offres sont pas fausses henri
paul desveaux leur enfoncer oiseaux
abolir les barrières à oz en ouvrir
alors osons faire honneur à cette belle
collectivité départementale qui comme je
le dis souvent est la maison de tous les
réunionnais le président rappelle la
force des agents du département ils sont
5000 quatre hommes et femmes mobilisées
au quotidien au service des familles
réunionnaises
[Musique]